You inherited a gift to see the future.
Get off!
Get off
That man is trying to kill you,
Cassie
Those girls are protection.
How do I even know if I can change anything?
The power of your mind has infinite potential.
This is an emergency.
That man is trying to kill you.
If you want to live, you have to trust me.
What is going on?
I can see the future.
Let's try that again.
Those girls have no idea the power they can unlock.
I will kill them first.
Get down,
Ezekiel Sims
he's got these crazy powers,
I'm more interested in why he's trying to kill us.
In the future, those girls are going to destroy.
If you want to live, then you have to trust me.
Welcome back everyone,
It's Charlie
Sony and Marvel released a bunch of Madame Web trailers
with new footage.
More details on how this all connects
to the larger spider-verse the Venom movies, the MCU.
Other Marvel Spider-Man spinoff movies.
Sony is doing right now, like Kraven, Morbius
And we also learned about Sony's plan
to make this movie a prequel to one of their previous
really big Spider-Man franchises in live action.
we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there are so much Spider-Man
related stuff happening this year.
We have the Kraven movie coming up after this.
We have Venom three coming later this year.
There's that friendly neighborhood Spider-Man TV show
that Marvel is doing on their side of things.
Then we have Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse
in Spider-Man four with Tom Holland's
version of Spider-Man.
so the next couple of years,
Spider-Man fans are going to be eating
good, like there is going to be a lot
a lot of Spider-Man related stuff. but.
During the new trailer footage,
they reveal more about her powers from the comics.
They haven't revealed which character
this guy is playing, that she's talking to,
who seemingly knows everything
about her powers and her mother when he tells her
she inherited a gift to see the future.
I think the idea is that he worked with her mother
in in the movie they have that funny line
where she references
her mother studying spiders in a foreign country.
The whole idea is that it's meant to help
set up the basis
for Madame Web's powers in her neurological condition.
Her mother was doing research
into her neurological condition
I think what they're doing is just putting a twist
on her origin story from the comics.
most people who have played the video games
or watched Spider-Man, the animated series know
a version of Mata Web in the comics.
Originally, she was just a woman from Salem, born
with a neurological condition
that took her eyesight and the ability to walk,
but caused her to develop incredible psychic powers,
using them to become a medium.
she's got a whole bunch of powers.
She's telepathic. She can astral project.
She's clairvoyant.
She has a greater precognition sense than normal
versions of Spider-Man have with their spidey sense.
Like,
we saw a version of the Spidey sense during Spider-Man.
No Way home.
Madame Web's
precognition is way more powerful than that.
She winds up using her abilities
to act as an oracle in a mentor
to versions of Spider-Man and Spider Woman
across the multiverse.
Like the Spider Force, for instance.
she gets involved in a lot of multiverse stories
featuring the web of life and destiny,
which they just canonized in Spider-Man
across the spider-verse.
There's some footage in the trailer depicting that,
like this is meant to be their depiction
of the web of life and destiny
you're meant to see her inside the web.
It's meant to show you her connection
to the web of life and destiny.
the actual web of life and destiny from the comics
is another way of describing the multiverse from, say,
Loki's strands of rope timelines he uses to construct
the new multiverse looking like the world tree.
That's why during Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse Spider-Man 2099
depiction of the web of life
and destiny starts out like a growing tree.
It has different ways of describing the same thing.
all the canon events that they talk about in that movie
serve as fixed points
in time that help control the normal flow of time
in those universes.
Preventing Nexus events to use a Loki term.
Madame Web's ability, at least at first in the movie
here, allows her to perceive
different strands of the web of life and destiny,
different timelines, potential futures in the movie.
I think they just refer to it as the web.
They don't see like the full web of Life
and Destiny title, in at least the way it comes off
initially as her powers
start to develop is just basic precognition.
but she becomes much more powerful than that
and can use the ability to mentally travel along
the strands, which is basically traveling through space
and time along timelines to other universes.
I think the major reason why they wanted Dakota Johnson
to play Madam
Web of all characters
like you could literally do any character you want.
They control like 900 characters because of the rights
they have to the Spider-Man character in the movies
is because Sony didn't have a version of Doctor Strange
or Marvel wouldn't let them use Doctor Strange,
and they needed a way to bring all the characters
together across
all their Spider-Man
spinoff movies inside this Venom Universe and connect
that to what's happening in the larger multiverse
with Avengers Secret Wars and stuff in the MCU.
so essentially she's like their major
crossover character because the last time
we had a crossover character, it was Tom Hardy's Venom
and it was actually Doctor Strange on his side
of things, on the MCU side of things that did
all the legwork to get in there and take him back.
and Web is just the work around
the Sony is using because they don't
have use of Doctor Strange
or Benedict Cumberbatch all the time.
so the idea of long term is that unless the Madame Web
movie does terrible like it does full morbid time,
Sony wants to disavow any knowledge
they ever made about a Web movie
like We don't know what you're talking about.
There is no Madam Web.
they'll bring her character back in the future.
Maybe Sidney Sweeney, Julia Carpenter,
maybe a few other Spider women.
Sidney Sweeney
just happens to be blowing up in other movies
in real life right now, Like she's super popular.
So I think Sony wants to do as much with that character
as possible.
input all of them in a team up movie with Tom Hardy's
Venom.
Kraven Morbius.
The Vulture, Any other Spider-Man related characters
that they introduced into this whole universe,
including whichever version of Spider-Man that they
decide to make the main Spider-Man of the universe in.
Apparently, originally,
Madame Web was designed to be a prequel
to Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man movies.
I bet a lot of people were thinking about this, too,
because technically the Madame Web
universe is just earlier
in the timeline of the Venom Universe.
And they've already revealed
that all the Sony Spider-Man movies
take place on that same Venom
Earth, like in the same universe.
remember when Morbius came out,
we saw all those Spider-Man Easter eggs.
A lot of it made it seem
like they were actually trying to make the universe
Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man universe.
Apparently Sony's original plan was include
all these references to Amazing Spider-Man,
Andrew Garfield in the Madam Web movie, supposedly,
they have all these references to Ezekiel
Sims coming back in time to kill all the spider women
before they get their powers, which we see
in all of the trailers.
But also he came back to kill Andrew Garfield,
Spider-Man before his mother,
Mary Parker, gave birth to him.
They're supposed to be
who Emma Roberts was playing in the movie.
That's why she's super pregnant
in all of the behind the scenes.
She's supposed to be pregnant
with Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man.
I just did a video about how Sony is trying
to get Marvel to bring back Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield for Spider-Man four and make an even bigger
multiverse movie than Spider-Man.
No Way Home was Kevin
Feige wants to wait till Secret Wars to bring them back
in one Spider-Man for to be a smaller street
level movie with Daredevil, Kingpin, a few new Sinister
Six villains is supposedly
Sony is pushing their crossover agenda,
like making this bigger and bigger,
making more and more crossover stuff going on here
because they changed their minds
about their original Madame Web plan or Andrew
Garfield said no way to their Madame Web movie.
And now Sony has removed
most of their bigger Spider-Man references
to Amazing Spider-Man in the movie, just like Morbius
did between the trailers in the final movie.
Like the trailer had all of these Tobey Maguire
Andrew Garfield references that they deleted
in the final version of the movie.
Supposedly,
the same thing just happened with the Madame Web movie.
in apparently now
Sony is trying to push for Tom Holland
to become the main Spider-Man
man of their spinoff Venom Universe.
I think part of the reason for this
is that they're worried about the box offices
for a lot of their Spider-Man spin off movies
that they're doing, just doing really, really poorly.
In hoping that Tom Holland showing up in
some of these movies will help legitimize them
and get asses in seats like, Tom Holland's in the movie
now we'll go see it.
Let me know in the comments, though.
If Andrew Garfield does not want to come back and Tobey
Maguire does not want to come back
to be the main Spider-Man of this Venom
spin off universe, then who do you want to be?
That means Spider-Man, Because it sounds like
Kevin Feige in the Marvel people are going to do
everything they can to keep Tom Holland from being in
like a billion different Spider-Man movies.
So it have to be a completely different version
of the character.
My theory right now, is it the solution
to their problem would just be to make a live action.
Miles Morales Spider-Man.
The main Spider-Man.
No, that universe, because they already said
that they were making a live action Miles Morales
movie back when across the Spider-Verse came out.
But they didn't say when they were going to release
that.
my only assumption right now
is that Matt and Web will just do
however it winds up doing probably
not going to make as much money as they want to do.
their remove most of their amazing Spider-Man
references to Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
and just be kind of ambiguous about which version
of Spider-Man eventually shows up in that universe.
Then they'll wait till after Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse comes out.
I'm sure it's going to make a crazy amount of money.
It'll probably be amazing.
then they'll publicly announce their live action
Miles Morales movie.
And just have that be the main Spider-Man of this Venom
spinoff universe.
maybe, maybe there are some cameos from Tobey Maguire
or Andrew Garfield
when they do that live action Miles Morales movie,
and he gets to be the older Spider-Man.
Hopefully they can do that
cameo without having to kill him off
like they did in Spider-Man into the Spider-Verse.
if you want the much older mentor like Spider-Man
to a younger Miles Morales live action Spider-Man,
I think Andrew Garfield or Tobey Maguire would be much
better picks than, say, like Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
He just way too young to be a mentor
to an even younger Spider-Man right now.
not quite.
But almost like they're doing a live action version
of Spider-Man
into the Spider-Verse, but treating it
like those events have already happened.
So they have to completely redo
the origin story in live action.
also, please do not kill Andrew Garfield.
Spider-Man in Service of Miles Morales is Origin story
that actually feels like something
that Andrew Garfield would want to come back for.
Personally, I also think that if Sony is so hot
on bringing Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire
back for other crossover movies,
why don't they just give them their own solo movies?
Like do a version of Amazing Spider-Man three in Tobey's
Spider-Man
for Just call them something slightly different.
Post all your theories in the comments below.
Andrew and Tobey come back for Secret wars.
What else do you want to see them come back for
click here to learn what's going on with Spider-Man
4 and click here for all that
brand new daredevil
born again footage in that first Look teaser
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!